most of your mathematical lives you've
been studying real numbers real numbers
include things like zero and one and
zero point three repeating and PI and E
and I could keep listing real numbers
these are the numbers that you're kind
of familiar with and then we explored
something interesting we explored the
notion of well what if there was a
number that if I squared it I would get
the negative one and we defined that
thing that if we squared it we got
negative one we define that thing is I
and so we defined a whole new class of
numbers which you could really view as
multiples of the imaginary unit so
imaginary numbers would be I and
negative I and and PI times I and E
times I so this might raise another
interesting question what if I combined
imaginary in real numbers what if I had
numbers that were essentially sums or
differences of real and imaginary
numbers for example let's say that I had
the number let's say I call it Z and Z
tends to be what we the most-used
variable when we're talking about what
I'm about to talk about complex numbers
let's say that Z is equal to is equal to
the real number five plus the imaginary
number three times I so this thing right
over here we have a real number plus an
imaginary number you might be tempted to
add these two things but you can't it
won't make any sense these are kind of
going and different well we'll think
about it visually in a second but you
can't simplify this anymore you can't
add those real number to this imaginary
number a number like this and let me
make it clear that's real and this is
imaginary imaginary a number like this
we call a complex number calm a complex
number it has a real part and an
imaginary part and sometimes you'll see
notation like this well if someone will
say well what's the real part what's the
real part of our complex number Z well
that would be the five
right over there and then they might say
well what's the imaginary part what's
the imaginary part of our complex number
Z and then they'll tell and then
typically the way that this function is
defined they really want to know well
what multiple of I is this imaginary
part right over here and in this case it
is going to be it is going to be 3 and
we can visualize this we can visualize
this in two dimensions instead of having
the traditional two-dimensional
Cartesian plane with real numbers on the
horizontal and the vertical axis what we
do to plot complex numbers is we on the
vertical axis we plot the imaginary part
so that's the imaginary part and on the
horizontal axis we plot the real part we
plot the real part just like that we
plot the real part so for example Z
right over here which is 5 plus 3i the
real part is 5 so we would go 1 2 3 4 5
that's 5 right over there the imaginary
part is 3 1 2 3 and so on the complex
plane on the complex plane we would we
would visualize that number right over
here this right over here is how we
would visualize Z on the complex plane
it's 5 positive 5 in the real Direction
positive 3 in the imaginary direction we
could plot other complex numbers let's
say we had the complex number a which is
equal to let's say it's negative 2 plus
I where would I plot that well the real
part is negative 2 negative 2 and the
imaginary part is going to be you could
imagine this is plus 1 I so we go 1 up
it's going to be right over there so
that right over there is our complex
number our complex number a would be at
that point of the complex complex let me
write that that point of the complex
plane and let me just do one more let's
say you had the complex number B which
is going to be
let's say it is let's say it's 4-3 I
where would we plot that well 1 2 3 4
and then let's see - 1 2 3 or negative 3
gets us right over there so that right
over there would be the complex number
be